Hi Leute, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Tofu. Der Podcast über Tofu. Heute ist der dritte Tag des Tofu-Kollottes.
Heia die Wau, Leute, und herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Wumelhunde-Experten-Podcast.
Weißt du, was ich halt gemacht habe? Ich habe heute so einen Block Tofu genommen.
Heia Leute, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Wum des Podcast UFO mit Flo und die Will. Richtig. Und mir. Stefan Tietze sitzt hier in mir. Vielen Dank an Max und Nele für dieses fantastische Intro. Toll, toll. Das wird ja immer besser. Ja, vielen Dank für die vielen tollen Intros. Jetzt kommen die Guten, sag ich mal. Wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre lang gesammelt. Jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt, wo die Guten kommen. Nein, ganz, ganz alle waren toll. Ganz, ganz toll. Auch viel gutes Feedback auf das Intro von letzter Woche, eine Gitarrenbegleitung, auch, ich bin gespannt, wie das Intro heute ankommt, ich bin mir sicher, fantastisch! Wir melden uns, wahrscheinlich der einzige Podcast Deutschlands, der sich noch trifft, in persona, um aufzunehmen, weil wir in der gleichen Stadt festhängen gerade, muss man sagen, wir sind bei den Köln, und nichts ist älter als die Podcast UFO-Folge der letzten Woche, muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, weil da innerhalb dieser paar Tage, wo wir jetzt nicht aufgenommen haben und die Folge veröffentlicht haben, hat die Welt so einen kleinen Turn genommen, der nicht so beabsichtigt war und auch nicht so vorhersehbar war. Von daher, alles gerade wie spannend. Obwohl, ich glaube, bei dir ist es noch nicht hundertprozentig angekommen, weil du hast mich jetzt gerade schön mit einem High Five infiziert. High Five begrüsst, dicke Umarmung, Kuss auf die Stirn. Aber bei High Five berührt man sich ja nur kurz. Drei Sekundenregel! Reicht das? Drei Sekundenregel! Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es die Drei-Sekunden-Regel gibt. Beim Coronavirus muss man sich mal informieren. Oder der ist halt so krass, der hat eine Zwei-Sekunden-Regel. Der ist halt fortgeschritten. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich stehe auf so Ausnahmesituationen, also das ist schon irgendwie spannend.
Ja.
Natürlich geht es auch vielen Leuten nicht gut und so weiter, aber man muss halt auch mal sagen, es ist schon noch mal cool, sowas zu erleben auf so eine Art.
Du, ich glaube, wer jetzt auf jeden Fall brilliert sind Prepper.
Prepper?
Die freuen sich richtig, die sagen lustig gemacht haben.
Die sitzen in ihren Bunkern mit ihren ganzen Auf-, mit ihren ganzen, was haben die dann so, so Staubmixturen. Staubsauger. Wir haben das völlig Falsche gebunkert. Wir haben zehntausend Staubsaugertüten. Warum kaufen wir da nicht so viel Milch? Es hält sich doch nicht lang, Milch. Milchpulver? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Milchpulver? Aber weil das ist für die Kinder vielleicht, wenn man schwanger wird während der Apokalypse, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich bin da nicht drin, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mich vor langer Zeit aus dem Prepper-Forum gemeldet. Also wie ich dich kenne, hat sich dein Leben ja auch gar nicht verändert. Überhaupt nicht. Null. Es ist ein bisschen besser geworden vielleicht sogar. Die Straßen sind ein bisschen leerer, angenehm leer für dich wahrscheinlich. Ja, ja. Aber auf der anderen Seite weiß ich gar nicht, ob man überhaupt noch Leuten begegnen kann, die davon gar nichts mitbekommen haben. Also gibt es Leute, die gar nichts mitbekommen haben? Big Brother House war ja so, die haben wir nichts mehr mitbekommen und den hat man gestern gesagt. Und das war sehr lustig, weil heute ist der achtzehnte, als wir gerade aufnehmen, und gestern am siebzehnten März haben die dem Big Brother House das erste Mal gesagt, was draußen gerade los los ist und die haben ja nichts mitbekommen. Das wäre doch die viel bessere Sendung eigentlich, Leute eine Woche einzusperren und dann so zu tun, als wäre danach irgendwie eine grosse Apokalypse ausgebrochen und die eigentliche Sendung fängt erst dann an. Also die Leute sind eine Woche eingesperrt, das filmt man aber gar nicht. Verkauft es als Big Brother. Genau. Und dann sagt, aber das ist eigentlich Big Brother Armageddon. Ja. Und dann sagt man denen nach Woche eins, wobei man muss aufpassen, was für ein Apokalypse-Szenario man denen halt verkauft. Weil zu krass, dann fragen sich alle, warum sind wir noch in einer TV-Show? Naja, oder du hast eine Stadt, eine komplette Stadt, die fake ist, oder dieses komplette Studio-Gelände ist fake. Und da bringst du die hin und sagst, okay, Sendung. Und dann aber nach einer Woche verlassen alle einfach diese Stadt. Und dann müssen die einfach, die Sendung wird auch nicht offiziell beendet, sondern die finden einfach irgendwann raus, irgendwie, wir kriegen keine Challenges mehr, hier passiert nichts mehr. Sind die Leute noch da, hallo, oder klopfen die so gegen die Scheibe. Dann gehen die so in die Regie rein, da ist so ein Skelett, was genau in dem Moment dann so umklappt. Ja, so Blutspuren, genau, und dann einfach noch so. Und dann müssen die ermitteln, also wie so ein Escape Room, ohne dass Leute wissen, dass sie in der Escape Room sind. Ja, Folter im Grunde. Im Grunde kann man sagen, psychologische Folter. Und dann verlassen die das Studio und dann ist alles mit Kameras belegt. Das finde ichassen das Studio und finden dann eine komplett leere Stadt. Finde ich super. Aber die Frage ist, ob man schnell genug, also ob die nicht einfach dann kilometerweit reisen und dann einfach eine normale Zivilisation vorfinden. Nee, da muss man genug hohe Mauern bauen. Aber ja, oder nicht. Nee, auf jeden Fall. Aber ich dachte mir auch, warum macht man das jetzt, weil jetzt reden die halt auch die ganze Zeit darüber in diesem Big Brother Haus. Gibt nichts nerviger als überall, wo man hinguckt, reden die Leute nur darüber. Da reden die jetzt auch nur dann darüber und man will ja auch mal Leute wie wir, man hört ja auch uns zum Beispiel, also wir reden jetzt auch nicht mehr so lange darüber, ist ja auch, uns ja auch denken wir immer, um halt ein bisschen vom Alltag zu fliehen. Eskapismus und das macht man doch, Big Brother ist doch auch nichts anderes, oder? Ich meine, gucke ich jetzt nicht persönlich, aber Leute, die das gucken, stellen wir vor, finden doch geil, dass die da jetzt weiterhin über Sophie und Timo sprechen, die im Whirlpool zusammen waren. Und jetzt reden die auch über Coronavirus, das will man ja auch nicht hören. Und das ist doch total lustig, wenn man einfach so eine Parallelwelt gehabt hätte für zwei Wochen oder wie lange das geht.
Und jetzt reden die halt auch darüber, aber halt schlechter informiert, weil sie halt nur eine Ansprache hatten, wo diese Big Brother-Stimme sagt, draußen herrscht übrigens ein Virus, SARS, Covid-19, zwei. Was, mit Astronauten? Wissen auch gar nicht. Werden die zurückgeholt? Werden Sonden zurück, Mars Rover zurückgeholt? Das ist das Erste, was wir machen müssen. Wir holen den Mars Rover zurück. Und also, okay, jetzt sind wir wissenschaftlich in der Frage, das jetzt mal nicht. Du kannst ja alles begründen. Es ist eine verrückte Zeit. Man kann alles mit, es ist eine verrückte Zeit. Auch gestern bin ich, da habe ich einen U-Turn des Todes gemacht, weil ich war ganz falsch unterwegs auf der Strasse. Und dann war aber leer und dann habe ich gesagt, komm, fuck, mitten auf der Kreuzung einen U-Turn gemacht, weil sonst wäre ich stundenlang in die falsche Richtung, hätte ich fahren müssen. Und ich hab mich immer mit dieser, ja, was soll ich machen, es ist eine verrückte Zeitgeste, entschuldigt. Und alle haben auch, ja, also Leute wollten sich jetzt aufregen über diesen weirden Fuck-up-Move, den ich dann auf der Kreuzung vollziehe, aber dann haben alle gesagt, ja, wir leben halt in verrückten Zeiten. Es ist ein bisschen mehr Solidarität auf jeden Fall, aber mal gucken, wie lange das noch so dauert. Ja, gut, auch schon vorbei dann mit den Hamsterkäufen und so, wo ich auch glaube, dass du auch nicht unbeteiligt warst. Wir wissen alle, du bist Klopapier-Connisseur. Ich liebe Klopapier, deswegen bin ich auch besonders hart getroffen von dieser Krise. Ich liebe Klopapier, gerne auch mal eine Rolle am Tag, Baller. Ja Also wirklich, ich kenne da nichts. Kennst du nichts, ne? Ja, ja. Bist du eher Team dreilagig oder Rudolf? Zehnlagig, da fängst du bei mir erst an. Wirklich? Bei zehn Lagen fängt das an. Ist das nicht dann so dick? Stehe ich mir vor, unangenehm vor. Nee, das muss quadratisch sein. Also so hoch, wie es breit ist. Also so quadratisch diese Blätter und die müssen noch mal genauso hoch sein. Und da geht es bei mir erst los. Das ist bei mir ein schlechter Tag, Stefan. Also deswegen ist das auf jeden Fall eine Krise für mich. Ich habe ja gemerkt, dass ich ohne es zu wissen gehamstert habe. Also man denkt halt so, oh diese dummen Leute, die Hamsterkäufe machen. Und dann bei mir ist es immer immer so, ich mache oft Nudeln und wir müssen auch mal darüber reden, ob diese 500-Gramm-Packungen überhaupt zeitgemäß sind, weil man braucht nie 500 Gramm. Ich habe das Gefühl, zwei Personen sind so 700 Gramm, eine Person ist weniger als 500 Gramm und es ist nie wirklich gut aufzuteilen. Und deswegen läuft es bei mir immer gleich ab. Machen die ja extra, ist ja auch, weil die dann wollen, dass du zwei Pakete kaufst für zwei Personen. Jetzt rächen sie sich, jetzt rächen sie sich für alles, was wir ihnen angetan haben. Für die ganzen Pizzen, die wir schön Falsche Gäste haben, die wir zusammengeklappt haben und dann wie so ein Sandwich Gäste haben. Nee, soll man ja. Soll man? Nee, nicht ganz, aber man soll die vierteln und dann zusammenklappen. Echt? Ja. Aber das ist, glaube ich, so New York-Style. Nee. So dieses Slice. Vierteln und zusammenklappen ist Italian-Style. Wirklich? Ja. Ja, wirklich. Machen da auch alle. Guckt mal richtigen Römern oder Neapolitanern oder Florentinern. Geht mal irgendwo hin und guckt mal, wie die die Pizza essen. Die vierteln die und dann nehmen die die Sandwich-mäßig. Gut, dann rechnen Sie sich dafür, dass wir sie mit Messer und Gabel gegessen haben. Schlagen zurück. Nee, man muss sie ja auch mit Messer und Gabel wie? Aber ist der Pizzaroller eigentlich italienischer abgesegnet? Ich glaube, es ist das Gegenteil. Dafür rechnen die sich, für den Pizzaroller. Stimmt, der Pizzaroller. Den Pizzaslicer. Ja, ja, das ist die Perversion. Und wenn du mit dem Pizzaslicer in Italien bist, fliegst du sofort raus. Und deswegen läuft es bei mir immer gleich, ich mache Nudeln, mache dann so 300 Gramm von 500, gehe einkaufen und denke mir, habe ich noch Nudeln, weiß ich nicht und kaufe eine neue Packung. Und so haben sich über die Wochen bei mir echt einige Nudelpackungen angesammelt. Das heißt, du bist für die nächsten 800 Jahre vorgesorgt. Auf jeden Fall. Es ist mathematisch schwierig, dann immer genau zu gucken, wie viel Nudeln ich brauche. Und so denkst du auch bei Klopapier. Ja. Reicht eine Rolle, hatte ich noch was zu Hause? Nee, komm, ich nehme mal zwei neue ganze Pakete mit. Ja, ich bin ja Programmierer und ich denke eigentlich immer nur binär. Ich denke in Null und Eins, Nudeln anwesend, Nudeln abwesend. Eine halbe Packung Nudeln existiert für mich nicht. Das ist für mich gleich wie keine Nudeln. Aber ganz unter uns. Und dann kaufe ich eine neue. Ich bin kein Profi, aber wären Codes nicht besser, wenn es auch 0,5er Schritt... Ich sag's nur, wenn es diesen Schritt... Ihr werdet mich verteufeln, sagen, haben wir probiert, ist nicht... Ich bin mir sicher, das ist dieser halbe Schritt, dem macht's besser. Ich kann jetzt auch konkret nichts dagegen sagen. Vielleicht brauchen wir da nochmal Schmieder im Call. Aber ich bin da deiner Meinung. Ja, 0,5er-Schritte. Ich habe mich selber nie getraut, das auszusprechen. Ich weiß, aber es braucht halt mal einen Vordenker. Dann muss er das mal aussprechen. Ja, und deswegen habe ich zu vielen Nudeln. Und ich habe mich fast schlecht gefühlt. Ich habe meinen Schrank aufgemacht und sehe da so irgendwie so zehn Pen-Packungen und denke mir so, oh Gott, ich bin einer von den Bösen. Oh nein, ich nehme ein, kann ich die zurückbringen in den Supermarkt? Und dann legt man so aus Solidarität so zwei Pen-Packungen ins leere Regal und einfach so, ja, für die Menschheit. Und ich habe ganz viele Asien-Nudeln ja gebunkert, weil ich die immer wegkaufe, den ganzen Bestand, weil es diese eine Marke nur manchmal gibt. Du lebst genau das Leben, was alle verteufeln gerade. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich bin der Satan hier, ich bin der Lucifer in der Situation. Aber festgestellt, alle abgelaufen. Ich habe letztens mal geguckt, weil es gab eine Rückrufaktion für genau meine Sorte und da stand dann drauf. Das kriege ich immer nie mit. Das kriege ich immer nur mit, wenn es viel zu spät ist. Ja, richtig. Es gibt eine Webseite über Rückrufaktionen. Das ist deine Startseite auch, wenn du auf Google Chrome klickst. Immer. Aber zum Glück gibt es Leute, die wissen, dass ich diese Nudelmarke mag. Du wurdest gewarnt von einem Podcast? Ich wurde gewarnt von einem Zuschauer, Zuhörer. So, hey, pass auf, deine favorisierte Nudelmarke. Sehr fantastisch. Deine favorisierte Nudelmarke gibt eine Rückrufaktion. Ja, und dann habe ich geguckt und da stand dann, diese Rückrufaktionen belaufen sich ja immer für so einen Zeitrahmen der Mindesthaltbarkeitsdaten. Da kann man dann immer ablesen, welche Chargen betroffen sind und welche nicht. Und deswegen musste ich mal, habe ich mal geguckt bei mir, ob ich solche habe und habe gemerkt, so was sind denn hier so die Haltbarkeiten von meinen Nudeln? So August 19, Mai 17, oh und merke, alle sind abgelaufen einfach. Aber ich meine, es sind Nudeln, hallo, was soll da passieren?
Ja, außer dass sie ablaufen. Nee, aber das ist interessant, dass man so wilde Muster an sich erkennt in solchen Zeiten. Ja? Ja, ich merke, dass ich ganz schlecht vorbereitet bin, mein Kostone ist komplett leer. Aber ich denke auch mal, bei der Ausgangssperre wird man ja auch noch in den Supermarkt gehen können oder in die Apotheke und wird sich ja eindecken können. Ähm, ich bin jedenfalls, also, ich habe es noch nicht ganz euch mal erklärt, wie meine Wohnsituation gerade ist, aber ich bin immer noch nicht umgezogen, richtig. Meine neue Wohnung wird gerade renoviert und meine alte Wohnung ist leer. Ich sitze in meiner alten Wohnung ohne Internet in Quarantäne. Man sagt übrigens Quarantäne, nicht Quarantäne und nicht Quarantäne. Nein, aber man sagt auch nicht Quarantäne, das ist das falsche Wort. Man sagt Quarantäne. Nein, aber Quarantäne, dazu wird man gezwungen. Man sagt nicht Quarantäne, das ist das falsche Wort. Nee, ich sag nur, darüber reden wir ja. Wenn du alleine zu Hause bleibst, dann kannst du sagen, du isolierst dich. Du brauchst gar nicht so emotional werden, mir ging es nur um die Aussprache von Quarantäne. Du hast schon recht, dass es das falsche Wort ist. Ja. Ja, der Einfachung halber. Quarantäne. Quarantäne ist das richtige Wort. Ja, vier Leute. Selbst Quarantaner. Selbst Quarantaner. Ja. Selbst Kasteiung. Die Siedler von Quarantan. So heißt das. Quarantan. Ja. Genau. Ja. Und jetzt hänge ich halt zu Hause in einer Wohnung, die vollgepackt ist mit Paketen. Und angenommen, jetzt kommt irgendwann mal eine Ausgangssperre, was ja nicht unwahrscheinlich ist und auch irgendwie sinnvoll, damit die Zahl der Ansteckung ein bisschen zurückgeht, weiss nicht, ob ich umziehen kann. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Hänge ich mal in einer alten Wohnung rum, wo nichts mehr drin ist, kein Internet, kahle Wände, es riecht nach Farbe und Laminatreiniger. Das ist wirklich das schlechteste Timing, du hast gerade alles aus deiner Wohnung rausgeräumt und mit deiner letzten Kiste, mit dem traurigen ETS, die noch drin, sagt jemand, nee, du darfst nicht mehr raus. Ich habe auch alles verkauft und im Prinzip nichts übernommen, an Gross, an Möbeln, weil alles nicht reinpasst in die neue Wohnung. Jetzt habe ich quasi nichts, ich bin in einer leeren Wohnung, ich könnte in meiner neuen Wohnung noch, die ist aber auch komplett leer und ist eine Baustelle obendrein. Aber hast du da Internet zumindest? Ja, da habe ich Internet zumindest. Okay. Naja, aber es ist eine Baustelle ohne Boden. Du, ich würde lieber in einem leeren Raum mit Internet sein, als in der Wohnung. Ja, aber in der alten Wohnung habe ich zumindest Küche und Kühlschrank. In der neuen habe ich nicht mal einen Kühlschrank. Ich habe nicht mal eine Küche. ich habe fliessend Wasser an guten Tagen. Das ist gerade ganz schlecht. Oh, das ist echt unbeheblich. Ich hänge gerade so ein bisschen zwischen zwei Welten und das hilft mir gerade gar nicht. Zumal alle Handwerker immer absagen und Möbellieferanten sagen, nee, nope. Die legen lachend auf, wenn ich die Frage, ob die Möbellieferungen noch kommen. Hustend auflegen. Ja, legen hustend auf, sterbend. Ja, das ist alles ganz, ganz blöd gerade. Ja, unangenehme Situation. Jetzt habe ich mir so ein Hotspot gemacht und der hält gerade erst mal noch. Mal gucken, wie lange noch. Ich bin ganz gespannt, bleibt aufregend. Zumal ja mein Job sich ja gerade nicht ändert. Ich habe ja so ein bisschen, habe ja gerade gesagt, ich stehe ja so ein bisschen auf Ausnahmesituationen und auch mal, es ist auf eine ganz perfide Art, das Gehirn ist ja auch ganz cool, dass mal alles neu ist und irgendwie anders und mal gucken, dass man mal sowas erleben kann, was man sonst aus Erzählungen gehört, kennt so. Und das ist nicht so geil, weil bei mir erinnert sich halt nichts. Ich kann meinen Job ja eins zu eins, drieblicher schreiben kann man ja auch von zu Hause aus. Du hast alle negativen Einflüsse, aber nicht die Freizeit. Ich hab nicht die Freizeit. Vielleicht ist es auch ganz gut, nicht so viel Freizeit zu haben, oder? Wenn du jetzt irgendwie wochenlang rumsitzt, ohne Internet und in dir in einer neuen Backstein-Wohnung. Ja, schwierig. Schwierig. Naja. Nun gut. Naja, ich hab viel Zeit, auf jeden Fall. Ich geniesse das. Ich versuche so ein bisschen strebermässig die Zeit rumzubringen.
Ich versuche aktiv Französisch zu lernen
und habe mir noch ein paar Bücher bestellt, die ich noch bekommen habe
und bin jetzt drin, schaue mir französische Filme an,
verstehe kein einziges Wort,
schaue sie in halber Geschwindigkeit mit Untertitel an,
verstehe dann auch kein Wort.
Und ja, irgendwann wird man auch ...
Ich habe gestern meine gesamte Blu-ray-Packung
auf die Strasse gestellt, Sammlung auf die Strasse gestellt, weil ich die nicht mitnehmen wollte, habe ich dann teilweise digitalisiert, habe ich auf die Strasse gestellt, zum Verschenken, und es sind innerhalb Minuten hat sich eine Traube gebildet, wo ich dachte, Leute, Leute, in diesen Zeiten könnt ihr, habe ich eine Traube verursacht, eine Menschentraube verursacht, in meiner Strasse, die Strasse war in heller Aufruhr, weil es passiert ja auch nichts, alle standen aus dem Fenster, sehen plötzlich, da steppt jemand Blu-rays auf die Strasse und die ganze Strasse war auf den Beinen, stand dann vor meinem Fenster, ich habe die auch unglücklich gestellt, muss man sagen, wieder auf meinem Fenster, stand dann alle davor. So eine Gasse und zwängst alle durch so einen Ladel. Ja, und dann schnell Massenpanik und Krankenwagen. Jedenfalls sind zwei Filme übergeblieben. Und man muss sagen, die waren so, also alle Filme waren sofort weg. Und zwei blieben dann über und es zeichnete sich ab. Und die blieben auch bis ganz spät abends über. Das heißt, also alle Filme waren sofort weg. Da war Shutter Island war dabei, The Dark Knight war dabei, Boogie Nights war dabei. Tolle Filme, alle weg, am Ende blieben zwei Filme über. Trauben sind die härtesten Kritiker, das ist wirklich die härteste Kritik. Zwei Filme blieben über, aber auch entschlossen mit Abstand über. Wie gesagt, habe ich es wieder reingeholt in die Wohnung, weil die so lange draußen lagen. Übergeblieben sind die Kunst der Fälschung, das ist die Dokumentation, die Beltracki-Dokumentation, die ich hier ganz toll finde, wo ich auch gesagt habe, die habe ich auch so trotzig wieder reingenommen.
Ja, ja. Hab gedacht, ja gut, dann nicht mega Doku, gucke ich gerne mir an.
Übrigens auch für euch eine Quarantäne, eben eine Quarantäne-Tipp, ein Selbst-Isolationstipp, damit ihr mal eine gute Dokumentation gucken könnt, der Fall Beltracki, die Kunst der Fälschung, sehr cool, bei einem Kunstfälscher aus Köln, der wahnsinnig coole Geschichte erlebt hat und alle krassen bekannten Bilder und Künstler gefälscht hat. Und Argo. Argo, es ist keine Zeit für Argo. Argo liegt noch rum. Das ist verrückt. Argo toller Film, aber vielleicht haben den auch schon viele. Nee, aber dafür wurden ... Oder vielleicht hat er so ein unaussagekräftiges Cover. Ich glaube, das glaube ich eher. Argo liegt noch da rum. Aber entschlossen neben so Filmen wie Shutter Island, Sicario und so, dann ist es dafür zu entscheiden, Argo aber dann doch liegen zu lassen. Das ist hart. Aber ja, das ist echt hart. Also klar, ich glaube, Oscar Oscarpreisträger. Ja, da freuen die sich die Filmmacher, aber das, glaube ich, ist dir noch mal ein Tritt ins Gesicht. Ja. Lieber keinen Oscar und genommen werden von Strassentrauben. Ja, ja. Nee, du willst lieber die Akzeptanz der Traube als die Akzeptanz des goldenen Mannes. Ich glaube, da bin ich... Also von daher alle... Bin ich froh... Also ich nehme ja auch an, dass viele meiner Werke, der Unterlagen, meine komplette Filmografie dabei war. Und unter anderem auch von des aber das darf ich nicht sagen. Das hat er mir geschenkt. Das müssen wir ausschneiden.
Du hast es digitalisiert und dann gedacht, das sollen andere... Nein.
Nee, nee, nee. Wir können es piepen, aber wir lassen es drin.
Du piepst es bitte. Also es wurde mir geschenkt von einem befreundeten...
Vom Schöpfer selbst.
Ein befreundeter Künstler hat mir die DVD seiner Serie geschenkt. Ich habe die nicht digitalisiert, ich habe die umgesehen auf die Strasse eingeschweißt auf die Strasse, die ist nicht mehr erschienen. Die ist doch nicht mehr erschienen. Der Fakt, dass die jetzt da draußen ist, ist eigentlich nicht gut. Wow. Die ist nicht mehr erschienen, diese Serie. Habe ich eingeschweißt auf die Strasse gestellt, ist mir im Nachhinein das aufgefallen, die war weg auch. Aber nicht Argo. Ben Affleck. Das ist schon Argo. Ich habe noch nie was auf die Straße gestellt und noch nie was davon genommen. Aber manchmal sieht man das, ich weiss nicht, das ist gerade ein laufender Umzug, darf ich da was nehmen? Steht da so ein Zuverschenken-Schild? Ja, Zuverschenken-Schild habe ich drauf. Zuverschenken-Schild? Zettel? Zugeslegt, ja. Pin? Hm, Pin? Mitit? Nee, nee, die nach vier und dann die Blu-rays da drangelegt. Was? Stein draufgelegt? Nein, die Blu-rays drangelegt. Drangelegt? Was heißt drangelegt? Die Blu-rays angestapelt gegen die Hauswand. Und zwischen Hauswand und Blu-rays. Die Zettel war an die Hauswand gelehnt und dagegen gestapelt die Blu-rays. Genau, ja. Aber wenn man dann die Blu-rays wegnimmt, dann ist der Zettel ja lose. Ja, käme ich mit klar. Ich finde, wer die letzte DVD nimmt, wer Argo genommen hätte, hätte auch die Pflicht gehabt, den Zettel mitzunehmen. Ach so. Aber so musste ich am Ende dann abends traurig nochmal raus, wie so Reversed Nikolaus. Man stellt was vor die Tür und am Ende ist nichts mehr über. War so reverse Nikolaus und musste dann rausgehen und hab dann traurig den Zettel wieder und Argo und Beltracki wieder reingenommen.
Man weiß nicht, ob der Zettel zu verschenken ist. Es gehen Leute vorbei und denken sich, ich brauche jetzt einen Zettel, aber ist der Zettel zu verschenken?
Das ist schwierig, schwierig zu sagen. Wie eine meiner absoluten Lieblingsgeschichten seit Jahren, habe ich mal gelesen, dass in der Stadt, ich weiß nicht, ob es in Amerika war oder irgendwo, wo eine neue Müllabfuhr eingesetzt wurde in der Stadt. Aus irgendeinem Grund, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine private Müllabfuhr war, ob es sowas gab, aber aus irgendeinem Grund gab es in der Stadt eine neue Müllabfuhr. Und die haben alles weggeschmissen, unter anderem die Mülleimer. Die haben die ganzen Mülleimer weggeschmissen. Die haben alle Mülleimer auf die Müllhalde geworfen und die Stadt musste komplett neue Mülleimer kaufen, weil die halt alles einfach, also die waren zu gut als Mülleute, die haben alles weggeschmissen. Das ist ein schmaler Grad. Es wurde in Deutschland, wurde ja auch irgendwann dann dieser, also zumindest bei uns in Kamen damals, wurde, was für mich als Kind mindblowing war, wurde dieser Roboterarm eingeführt. Wie? Gibt es das nicht in Süddeutschland bei dir irgendwann? Bei uns gab es die Umstellung. Die Mülltonne oder was? Ja, da gab es keine Müllmänner mehr, sondern gab es so einen Müllarm. Ja. Da kam so ein Auto an und dann hat er so einen ausziehbaren Arm und der hat die Mülltonne genommen, oben eingeleert und dann die Mülltonne wieder hingestellt. Und ich war immer ein großer Fan, ich habe immer gewartet, bis die Müllabfuhr kam und habe schlauert am Fenster und habe gewunken und habe immer zugeguckt. Und irgendwann kam dann halt dieser neue Wagen und dann gab es keine Müllmänner mehr, sondern kam so ein ganz gruseliger, utopischer, Davor habe ich, glaube ich, mal aus Versehen abends,
wenn ich mich immer aufgewacht bin,
dass meine Eltern ins Wohnzimmer und dann lief der Krieg der Welten.
Das hat mich sehr erinnert daran,
weil dann kam plötzlich dieser neue futuristische Müllabfuhrwagen
mit diesem Arm, Roboterarm,
der viel zu aggressiv diese Mülltonne nimmt,
reinleert, dann auch so ruckelt, damit alles rausgeht.
Nee, das ist auch kein Genießen.
Und dann so auf die Straße zurückwirft.
Und dann lag die dann ... Weil der hat noch nicht so so viel, mittlerweile sind die ja so ganz filigran und schrecken dann noch so den kleinen Finger in die Luft. Und jetzt, damals war noch so BAM, wurde wieder auf die Straße gestellt und der Deckel lag dann so halb daneben und als Kind dachte ich so, hoho, was passiert hier? Einfach in irgendeine Richtung wird die Mülltonne nach oben einfach gefahren. Weg damit. Und dann zehn Minuten später aus dem All rum. Grossartig. Ja, aber das hat dann deinen Müllabfurtraum zerstört. Ja, genau. Hast du Angst vor Maschinen bekommen? Jetzt habe ich Angst vor Maschinen. Ja. Kann man so sagen. Und dann ist es dann weggefahren und seitdem kam es dann doch jede Woche. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen eigentlich die genau invertierte Diskussion von uns letzte Woche. Wer produziert Fabriken ist, wer schmeisst Mülleimer weg. Wer produziert Müll? Wer entsorgt das, was entsorgt. Also wenn du einen alten Müllwagen hast. Wo landet das alles? Ich habe auch so viel weggeschmissen jetzt wegen dem Umzug, so an altem Messie-Zeug. Man kann sich schwer von Dingen trennen, ist mir auch mal aufgefallen. Da fiel mir mein Kellerabteil ein, was ich noch hatte in der alten Wohnung. Das fiel mir irgendwann so ein, da habe ich es auch gemacht, das kann auch nicht mein Ernst sein. Da habe ich dann so alte Unterlagen noch von meinem Bachelor und so gehabt. Und dann wirft man das weg und man denkt, wo kommt das alles eigentlich hin? Also ich habe ja säckeweise Müll dann gehabt noch. Die Vorstellung ist so gruselig, dass das ja alle haben so viel Kram, Müllkram. Wo landet das alles? Müllhalde wird verbrannt oder so? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber wie entsorgt man Müllwagen? So, das ist dann auch so, wer wirft den weg? Ja, es gibt ja vor allem auch so alte Müllwagenfriedhöfe dann wahrscheinlich. Genau wie es ja Flugzeugfriedhöfe gibt. Der A380 wird ja nicht mehr verlängert und nicht mehr dann, wird jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig TÜV geprüft, doch, aber er wird nicht mehr ausgebaut und geupdatet und so weiter. Und da ist auch mittlerweile der erste A380 auf so einen grossen bekannten Flugzeugfriedhof gekommen, wo dann ganz viele Flugzeuge rumstehen. Ja, bei unserer Nähe, wo ich aufgewachsen bin, da gab es einen grossen Hügel und da hieß es immer, da ist Müll drin. Also das war eine Müllhalde und anscheinend gibt es dann so einen Zyklus von Müllhalden, wenn die halt voll sind, dann pflanzt man da was, keine Ahnung, ob man da aktiv was pflanzen muss oder ob man dann also Erde drüber schüttet und dann wächst da was. Und mein Traum als Kind war es immer, da irgendwann mal zu graben, zu gucken, was man da so findet. Was habe ich davon abgehalten, von diesem utopischen Traum? Da mal zu graben, wenn ich gross bin, könnte ich da mal graben. Was habe ich da gehindert? Dass ich die Verhältnisse nicht gut einschätzen konnte, dass ich nicht wusste, muss man da jetzt, als Kind checkst du ja gar nichts, also mittlerweile bin ich viel weiter, was das angeht, wo ich nicht wusste, muss man da jetzt, also ist das so eine dünne Hülle, also sind das so zwei Zentimeter Erde und dann kommt direkt irgendwie so ein Schatz oder ist das ein Kilometer tief, ist das so eine richtige Maulwurstaktion? Ich konnte mir das nicht vorstellen, ich habe nur diesen Hügel gesehen und da hieß es, da drin ist Müll. Das ist wie wenn du jemanden Berg zeigst und da sagst du, da drin ist Gold und du weißt nicht. Ich finde es lustig, dass selbst als naives Kind du kein Driver hattest, dem nachzugehen. Null. Du fandest die Idee besser als die Aktion. Ja, ich habe immer davon geträumt, weil ich war ein großer Fan der Batcave. Batman hat mich nicht so interessiert, so diese Geschichten, das Rumfahren und so. Verbrechen lösen. Was war nicht meins. Mysteries klären. Aber ich fand die Batcave cool, die Vorstellung, eine eigene Höhle zu haben, die niemand kennt. Und dann so mit dem Aufzug runterfahren. Und dann habe ich immer versucht, bei uns im Garten, war meine Vorstellung, niemand weiss, dass da ein geheimer Eingang zu einer Höhle ist. Aber ich weiss. Ja, bis deine Mama irgendwann sagt, du Florian, ich habe mal deine geheime Höhle aufgeräumt. Nein, sie muss sterben, sie weiß zu viel. Und dann dachte ich mir eines Tages so, nee, jetzt hör mal auf, nur immer davon zu träumen, diese geheime Höhle zu haben und fang jetzt mal an. Dann habe ich im Garten angefangen zu graben und wirklich so nach vier Schaufelstichen gedacht, no fucking way, gräbst du ein Loch groß genug, dass du da irgendwie deine ganzen Kleidung und da so ein eigenes Zimmer unter der Erde hast, habe ich sofort aufgegeben, sofort aufgegeben. Hat es mal einer durchgezogen, ist meine Frage, weil diese Gedanken hatte man ja, also vom Baumhaus bis irgendwie ein geheimes Zimmer, geheimer Gang, jeder wollte auch mal zu seinem besten Kumpel einen Tunnel graben. Jetzt gibt es ja acht Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt ungefähr, sagen wir mal, für die Vereinfachung jetzt. So, mit einem Sinn, zwei runterholen, dann hast du, sagen wir mal, die Chance, dass einer das mal gemacht hat, ist hoch. Ist hoch, ja. Ist ungefähr gleich ungleich hoch. Ich glaube, es gibt für alles die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es einer gemacht hat, relativ hoch. Du kannst jede Wahrscheinlichkeit noch so klein mal acht Milliarden multiplizieren und es kommt ein solider Wert raus. Also du kannst einfach mal sagen, hatte jemand schon mal zwei Hüte auf gleichzeitig? Das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. Da gibt es Tausende wahrscheinlich, vielleicht sogar Zehntausende Menschen. Oder hatte jemand mal so, keine Ahnung, Socken an den Händen und Handschuhe an den Füllen? Ja. Vielleicht, vielleicht. Vielleicht hat aber einer mal einfaches durchgezogen, da ist irgendwie so einen krassen Gang. Ja, ja, ja. Ja, irgendwann findet man das alles. Aber dann fangen ja die Probleme erst an. So, wie, was ist die Zimmeraufteilung in dieser Bad Camp? Ja, ja, genau. Wie hoch macht man das? Ja. Spaltmasse. Ja. Da kommen ja dann die Erwachsenenprobleme. Erdrutsche. Ich meine, es gibt ja immer wieder Erdrutsche. Immer wieder. Und das sind wahrscheinlich einfach große Höhlensysteme, die einbrechen.
Ja, von Kindern gebaute Höhlensysteme.
Apropos Katastrophen, wir haben ja in unserer letzten Folge angesprochen den Weddingknall.
Für alle, die es nicht wissen, wir sind auf der Suche nach einem Abenteuer, das handlich ist.
Ja, Pocket-Abenteuer.
Ja, und uns wurde der Weddingknall vorgeschlagen, dass 2014 gab es einige Knalle, Knalle, Knalls in Wedding in Berlin und wir haben uns überlegt, ob wir das aufrollen sollen, weil das ist ja schon sechs Jahre her, aber wir haben eine Mail bekommen von jemandem aus Berlin, der in Wedding wohnt und der meinte, diesen Knall gibt es immer noch. Es ist noch nicht gelöst, es gibt immer noch diesen Knall hin und wieder. Und wir haben Außenkorrespondenten in Wedding? Ja, absolut, wir haben Leute in Wedding, es ist wie gesagt ein Stadtteil in Berlin und es gibt diesen Knall immer noch. Es gibt diesen Knall immer noch, aber in der Nacht war es ja von mehreren Knall Knellen, Lärm, Erzeugnissen. Es hieß immer, es gibt einen Knall, ich glaube so zwischen 22 und 1 Uhr oder so was, oder 23 und 1 Uhr war das Zeitfenster, und den gibt es immer wieder. Ist es nicht der eine Nachbar, der einfach sehr laut nach Hause kommt und die Tür zumacht? Kann sein, das Problem ist ja, dass die Knalle so weit auseinander liegen. Wenn es hintereinander knallen würde, könnte jemand mal sagen, okay, wo ist er, wo ist er, man ehrt sich. Aber so ein Tag ist halt schwierig, deswegen auf jeden Fall schwierig. Ja, Julius hat das geschrieben und der erzählt uns auch von grossen Bunkeranlagen mit einem Flackturm in Wedding aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg im Volkspark Humboldthain und vielleicht könnte es daher kommen, aber er meinte,, es gibt immer mal wieder diesen Knall. Aber das klingt so, als ob es unrücklänglich wäre. Er schreibt hier, ich wohne seit mittlerweile sechs Jahren in Berlin-Wedding und bin dementsprechend Ohrenzeuge des Wedding-Knalls. Ich habe ihn zusammen mit meiner damaligen Freundin, warum muss man ständig erwähnen, das ist wirklich, das ist alle mit euren Direchtsbeziehungen. Und nach unserem Einzug erstmals leibhaftig miterlebt. Er war so ohrenbetäumend laut, dass wir uns sicher waren, dass gerade etwas gravierendes Geschehen sein musste. Da hat jemand aber deutsch durchgespielt. Ist das Plusquamperfekt? Oder was ist das? Ein einzelner Donnerschlag, der seinesgleichen sucht. Jetzt ist er im Präsens wieder. Im Laufe der Nacht knallte es mehrmals, aha, sodass wir aus dem Schlaf hochschreckten, auch bei geschlossenen Fenstern. Sodass wir, obwohl wir gerade harten Geschlechtswag, ja, das fehlt eigentlich noch. Kurz innerhielten, um dann so leidenschaftlicher fortzusetzen. Anschliessend war es wieder Mucksmäuschenstill. Wie hat er das geschrieben? Zusammengeschrieben mit CK? Er schreibt selber ein schönes Wort. Ein schönes Wort, aber glaube ich, das kann man so schreiben. Ja, auf jeden Fall, er sagt, es gibt es aber mehrmals oder mehrfach pro Nacht. Er weiß aber auch nicht genau, was es sein könnte, aber ohrenbetäubend laut schreibt er. Von ohrenbetäubend laut bis mucksmäuschenstill war also in der Nacht alles dabei. Wahnsinn. Heißt aber, wenn es jetzt immer noch ist, aber es klingt nicht mehr so problematisch. Man hat sich wahrscheinlich daran gewöhnt, in Wedding hört man das schon gar nicht mehr. Als Ortsfremder denkt man, boah, was zum Teufel war das denn gerade? Das war ja ohrenbetäubend. Aber eigentlich müsste man das doch rauskriegen, oder? Man installiert einfach so ein paar Mikrofone in Wedding und guckt dann, bei welchem ist es am lautesten. Hast du eigentlich, das war wahrscheinlich nicht die letzte Folge gehört, wo ich diesen Wedding-Knall eingespielt habe? Hast du ihn eingespielt? Ja. Nee, habe ich nicht gehört. Lächerlich leise, lächerlich erbärmlich. Hör mal rein, hör dir mal die ganze Folge an. Und es gab einen Reporter, der hat da Tonaufnahmen gemacht, aber halt lächerlich. Also man hört nur so ein ... Es ist halt wirklich erbärmlich. Aber vielleicht lag das ja am Mikrofon oder so. Aber man muss doch einfach mal Mikrofone eine ganze Woche lang laufen lassen können. Okay, Auftrag an euch, Hausaufgabe an euch, liebe Außenkorrespondenten des Podcast-Sofos in Berlin Wedding. Ihr müsst jetzt mal eure Mikrofone aufstellen. Und ich glaube, da können wir sogar einfach, wenn wir uns auf ein Fabrikat einigen, können wir da ja schon mal, wenn ihr das die ganze Nacht laufen lassen würdet, irgendwie lautet euch Audacity runter oder so ein Programm, was kostenlos ist. Ja. Oder nehmt Garage Band. Und dann kann man ja vergleichen, bei wem es am lautesten ist. Und dann updaten wir euch jede Woche mal wieder. Und dann haben wir wirklich so ein Pocket-Abenteuer, wo wir nicht mehr aus unserer Selbstisolation raus müssen. Ja, grossartig. Ihr müsst eigentlich auch nicht raus. Ihr müsst auch nicht raus. Ihr könnt einfach nur auf euren Balkonen Mikrofon stellen. Ja, und dann gucken wir das so, dass wir in jedem Quadranten jemanden haben, der da mal kurz gerade in selbst... Weil es ist ja Wedding so, Wedding ist ja nur ein Teil von Wedding ist riesig, aber Wedding ist ja dann, naja, wahrscheinlich auch noch recht groß, aber man kann das ja bestimmt eingrenzen. Und dann müssen wir uns halt immer nur immer näher rücken und dann irgendwann sind wir angekommen und dann wissen wir es. Und vielleicht ist es jemand, der eine Bad Cave baut und da irgendwie Sprengungen durchführt oder sowas oder irgendwie dann keine Ahnung squash spielt jede Nacht oder sowas man weiß es nicht genau aber es ist auf jeden Fall glaube ich ein Rätsel das wir lösen können. Meine neue Wohnung ist sehr hellhörig wo wir gerade bei Knall sind. Aber nach außen oder du hörst viel was deine Nachbarn machen? Ja, weiss ich noch nicht genau. Ich war noch nicht so lange dann da und vor allem nicht nachts.
Aber es ist sehr lustig, dass mir, dass an beiden Tagen Nachbarn, also am ersten Tag kam ein Nachbar von rechts und am zweiten Tag kam ein Nachbar von links. Und beide haben unabhängig voneinander im zweiten Satz erwähnt, ja, ist ja auch wahnsinnig hellhörig hier. Da ist es schon ganz gut, wenn man sich sehr gut miteinander versteht und sehr gut auskommt miteinander. Und auch, weil man erfährt ja schon viele voneinander. Und bei beiden war es so, halt dein dummes Drecksmaul im Nebensatz, halt deine Klappe, wenn du fürs erste Mal, wenn du feierst, dann holen wir sofort die Polizei, wir hören alles, bist du Single, ja, Gott sei Dank. Aber Wohnungssuche, ey, vor allem, da hast du ja das alles hinter dir. Hast du die Wohnung gefunden, eingezogen, Möbel gekauft und dann heißt es, ja, ihr hört ja alles, was der Nachbar macht. Ja, und da regnet es rein, da regnet es rein, da ist eine Kamera, ciao! So war es ein bisschen, aber dann war alles schnell vergessen, weil die Nachbarin, eine der Nachbarin, die wir sich vorgestellt haben, hat mir dann Kekse gebacken, ganz Hollywood-Filmmässig Klischee, hat mir Kekse gebacken und mir die geschenkt, fand ich ganz toll. Wow. Und waren super lecker. Das haben wir gesagt. Und da war dann auch alles vergeben und vergessen, dachte ich mir auch, die kann alles von mir hören, ist mir auch alles egal. Was waren das für Kekse? Kekse, gemahle Kekse mit Smarties reingebacken.
Oh, nicht schlecht.
Wobei,
kleine Kritik,
wenn man die reinbackt,
verlieren die an Farbe.
Ich verstehe schon die Idee dahinter. Ich streue die Farbe dann überall.
Ich mag die Idee.
Sobald man
die in den noch flüssigen Keks gibt,
den Keks backt,
rausholt, ist nicht mehr
Das ist ein, das wir, ist nicht mehr so schön, weil dann verliert es der Smarty halt an Farbe. Ja. So, und dann kann man, wie gesagt, ich verstehe die Idee und ich verstehe, wenn man kommt gedanklich und die sehen auch schön aus und man will schöne Sachen auf seinen Keks packen, aber danach ist es nicht mehr so schön. Und dann jetzt einmal vielleicht, dass es da draußen ist, der Satz vorher Gedanken macht. Das heißt, du willst ja eigentlich was genießen. Genau, und vielleicht vorher mal Gedanken machen, dass es danach nicht mehr so schön aussehen. Mach das mal. Wollen wir mal alle kurz mal aufhören, Smarties einzupacken. Ja, für alle, die gerade eine Hand Smarties in der Hand haben. Und es gerade in Keks packen wollen. Was ist deine Empfehlung? Erst backen und dann reindrücken oder was?
Geht glaube ich nicht, weil der Keks dann hart ist. Ich glaube, Smarties sind einfach nicht die beste Idee.
Oder man muss mal an Smarties schreiben, dass sie Backsmarties rausbringen, die nicht an Farbe verlieren.
Aber so geht es halt nicht weiter.
Aber geh mal zu ihr und gib mir das als Feedback. Das fände ich richtig gut. Ja, ich auch. Ich muss einfach nur laut sagen, glaube ich. Wahrscheinlich hat sie das Feedback schon bekommen. Ehrlich gesagt, wahrscheinlich hat sie es schon bekommen. Ich weiß nicht, wie hellrisch die Wohnung ist.
Wahrscheinlich macht sie das immer so, wenn jemand neu einzieht, dann bringt sie dem Kekse und legt sich dann so an die Wand und hört genau so, das ist ja alles grün drin und ihr läuft so leise eine Träne runter. So leise, dass ich es aber trotzdem noch höre. Frau Oberbeck? Werbung. Erklär mir mal Quantenphysik in 15 Minuten.
Naja, es gab Max Planck und dann gab es auch Newton und dann wurden verschiedene Gesetze. Wie fällt es so schwer? Wenn du gute, verkürzte Zusammenfassungen von komplexen Themen haben willst und wenig Zeit hast, dann schau doch mal bei Blinkist vorbei. Ich kenne Blinkist, Blinkist ist mega. Ja, du kennst es besser als ich. Es ist wirklich fantastisch und du kannst wirklich ganz toll angeben mit Angeberwissen. Es ist eigentlich die perfekte Seite für Podcaster, die perfekte Möglichkeit, um dir Blenderwissen draufzuschaffen und so zu tun, hast du von allem eine Ahnung. Ja. Du lernst aber wirklich auch was. Jeder von uns hat irgendwie einen ganzen Stapel Bücher zu Hause rumlegen von Sachbüchern, die man sich mal geholt hat zu Weihnachten, aber die man einfach nicht liest. Und hier könnt ihr es verkürzt machen in 15 Minuten. Über alles, Produktivität, Psychologie, Wissenschaft, alles. Und ihr müsst es nicht mehr lesen, sondern die gibt es auch als Hörbücher. Das heißt, ihr könnt euch einfach 15 Minuten in der U-Bahn alle möglichen Sachthemen, die euch interessieren, anhören und lernt viel dabei. Richtig, alle Titel gibt es auf Deutsch und Englisch und das Beste ist, wenn ihr auf unsere Landingpage geht, das ist nämlich blinkist.de slash ufo, dann kriegt ihr 25% auf das Jahresabo. Blinkist Premium. Tut das auf jeden Fall bei blinkist, b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t.de schaut vorbei, es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, in 15 Minuten werdet ihr ein klügerer Mensch. Wäre jetzt viel Spaß bei der Folge. Mit der dummen, dummen Folge. Werbung. Zwei Fragen. Erstmal würde ich gerne die Statistik bekommen, und das können wir uns alle mal in den Terminkalender schreiben, jetzt in die To-Do-Liste. Ich will wissen, ob in neun Monaten die Geburtsrate steigt. Erstens. Und zweitens, wie viele dusselige Mails werden gerade geschrieben?
Alle Menschen langweilen sich gerade.
Eben mal, also erfahrungsgemäß, schwierige Zeitpunkte.
Leute fangen an, dumme Dinge zu machen, dumme Fragen zu stellen.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele belanglose Kack-Mails gerade geschrieben werden.
So nach dem Motto, Smarties, könnt ihr nicht mal Smarties rausbringen, die in einem Backvorgang nicht die Farbe verlieren?
Vor allem dieses ganze Homeoffice-Zeug. Wir alle wissen, dass Homeoffice bedeutet, man arbeitet nicht. Und dann ist ja, hat er dann vielleicht so ein schlechtes Gewissen und denkt sich, ja, ich muss halt schon noch ein paar Mails schreiben. Und schreibt dann so Sachen so, und ist das angekommen? Und er so, ja. Und dann war so, okay, gut, dann ist ja gut. Das ist eine Arbeit, nochmal bei jemandem nachzufragen. Oder irgendwie so ein Kram, wo man halt einfach denkt, man muss halt irgendwas tippen. Man arbeitet zu Hause nicht, das ist immer Quatsch. Leute im Homeoffice sind immer, bei Slack, was unser Firmenprogramm auch immer ist, sieht man immer dieses Homebutton, auch bevor das alles jetzt war, sieht man immer schon dieses Homeoffice-Symbol.
Diesen Leuten, die antworten ja auch nie. Die sind ja auch nicht mal
online. Da kann man denen schreiben,
man weiß, man kriegt nichts zurück, irgendwann schreibt man denen gar nicht mehr, weil man
den geht, ja Urlaub. Also Homeoffice habe ich
nie akzeptiert. Ne, ich auch nicht.
Es ist super schwer,
zu Hause sich irgendwie aufzuraffen
zu arbeiten. Deswegen
gibt es ja auch Leute,
die sagen, man braucht für ein Homeoffice
ein eigenes Zimmer, auch wenn da nichts, einfach damit man sagt, jetzt bin ich im Büro sozusagen, oder das wird auch oft vorgeschlagen an Studenten oder so, gut, hier haben jetzt in der Regel nicht so viel Platz, aber wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, von zu Hause irgendwas arbeitet oder irgendwie eine Masterarbeit schreibt oder so, dann zumindest eine andere Ecke, wo man sagt, okay, da setze ich mich mit meinem Laptop hin auf die Couch und da arbeite ich nur daran, dass man das so örtlich trennt. Ich finde es auch gemein, sich immer lustig zu machen, die ins Café gehen zum Arbeiten an Laptops. Ich kann das total nachvollziehen. Ich finde das total schön, weil da bist du unter Leuten, da arbeitest du anders, da arbeitest du vor allem. Ja? Da bist du dann da hin, um zu arbeiten, zu kommen. Also zu Hause zu arbeiten, finde ich ganz schwierig.
Es ist total schwierig. Und auch generell sich so zusammenzuweisen, gewisse Arbeiten zu machen, ist auch schwer. Ich hatte ja mal diesen Würfel, den man so hinlegen kann oder dann so die Zeit. Wieso hattest du den? Was ist denn damit passiert? Ich hab den immer noch, aber der hatte leider einen essentiellen Designfehler, der es mir leider vermiest hat, den zu benutzen. Und zwar, man kann dann den nächsten Tag planen und, also das ist wie gesagt so ein Würfel und je nachdem wie man den liegt, zählt er die Zeit, wie lange er so liegt. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, okay, ich will jetzt keine Ahnung eine halbe Stunde Sport machen, dann legt man den auf Sport und dann misst er die Zeit. Macht er jemals auf Sport? Nein. Und das Problem an diesem Würfel war leider, ich weiss nicht, ob es mittlerweile immer noch so ist, aber zumindest zu der Zeit war es so, dass man den nächsten Tag planen konnte und du sagst, ich will, keine Ahnung, zwei Stunden Steuererklärung machen und dann musstest du aber angeben, ich will es von zwölf bis vierzehn Uhr machen. Du konntest nicht einfach sagen, ich will morgen zwei Stunden Steuern machen, egal wann, und dann zählt ja halt einfach mit, wann du es machst, sondern du konntest es nur in diesem Zeitfenster machen.
Was für mich war so, nee, das ist überhaupt nicht das, was ich will. Ich will das mir nicht vorschreiben von dir, wann ich meine Steuererklärung mache. Nee, weil dann bräuchte ich den ja auch nicht. Ich kann mir selber vornehmen, dass ich von zwölf bis vierzehn Uhr mache. Was ich alleine schlecht kann, ist mir flexibel die Zeiten einteilen, dass ich halt immer mal wieder oder einfach sage, okay, jetzt mache ich Steuer und dann sage ich, und wie lange habe ich es jetzt schon gemacht oder wie lange habe ich es gestern gemacht, egal, er hat auf jeden Fall nicht funktioniert und zumindest für mich nicht, vielleicht für andere schon, aber es ist echt schwierig, sich zusammenzureissen und ich weiß auch nicht, ob das schlimmer wird, irgendwie so mit der Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, man klickt nochmal irgendwo rein, hat 50 Tabs offen, schwierig. Ich habe auch immer Tabs offen. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde immer unproduktiver. Auch zum Beispiel, ich habe mir letztens, wo ich jetzt gerade bei der Steuer bin, weil da bin ich extrem inkompetent, ich habe mir letztens, weil das kombiniert auch oft so soziale Ängste oder so, dann mit so Steuerberater oder irgendwie so jemanden anrufen, Vermieter oder so, und ich habe mir letztens wirklich vorgenommen, morgen liest du die Mail. Nicht, du antwortest auf die Mail, nicht irgendwie, du machst was, sondern du liest morgen die Mail, weil da kommt eine Mail und ich lese die nicht. Und dann habe ich mir explizit vorgenommen, morgen liest du die. Und dann habe ich sie gelesen und dachte mir, yes, du hast was geleistet, nichts weiter gemacht, aber ich habe sie zumindest gelesen. Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall eine neue Stufe, die du erreicht hast. Das ist eine neue Stufe, weil ich bin, ich habe das Gefühl, ich hänge da zehn Jahre hinterher und ich habe auch irgendwie mittlerweile Lust, das Ganze in so eine eher destruktive Ecke zu wenden. Also dann einem Steuerberater, der sagt, ich brauche dann noch ihre Lohnsteuerabrechnung und man schickt dem dann irgendwie so einen Flyer von so einem indischen Imbiss. Oder von deinem Bandprojekt, was nächste Woche im The Clam spielt. Ja, und dann so, nee, nee, ich brauche ihre Lohnsteuerabrechnung. Und man schickt ihm dann einfach irgendwie so eine leere Klarsichtfolie. Nee, nee, ihre Lohnsteuerabrechnung. Ach so, ja, und schickt man so einen Snoopy-Sticker. Oder die von letztem Jahr oder so zumindest. Und dann irgendwann sagt er auch so, wir lassen das an der Stelle einfach so. Wie dumm kann man sein, bevor Leute sagen, du verarschst mich doch. Ich glaube, beim Steuerberater kannst du ziemlich weit treiben, weil er für jede Mail, die er schreibt, ja auch Minutenabrechnungen macht, wo du, glaube ich, irgendwann finanzielle Probleme bekommst. Eigentlich stimmt, eigentlich muss man anders denken, je dümmer man ist, desto glücklicher ist der. Ja, also ich glaube, mein Steuerberater freut sich sehr über jede Frage, die ich habe. Was der ja stimmt, was der ja gar nicht will, ist, dass man superkompetent in Steuerrecht ist und so und das alles kann. Da muss ich auch wirklich sagen, ich fühle mich da, ich halte mich nicht für doof, aber alles, was Steuerrecht angeht, muss man bei mir wirklich von ganz vorne anfangen. Ich habe davon nichts eine Ahnung, ich komme mir vor wie der letzte Mensch, mir ist es mittlerweile unangenehm auch und ich lüge auch meiner Steuerberaterin offen ins Gesicht, dass ich es verstanden habe, einfach, weil ich es nicht mehr, ich will es nicht zugeben, ich will mein Stolz nicht verlieren. Und sie malt schon immer Strichmännchen und es ist schon immer alles sehr anschaulich und mit wachs mal stiften und um mich zu beglücken angerichtet dann da aber der twister teppich ist ausgerollt so das macht alles an diesem badezimmer sagt es ist gerade für mich so damit ich mich gut fühle und es einigermaßen anschaulich verstehe und so wird noch mal nochmal so der Kinderkanal-Fernseher reingeschoben mit der Steuer-DVD. Und dann halt wie damals, erklärt man mir das anschaulich, ich verstehe es nicht. Nee, ich verstehe es auch nicht. Dann sagt dann immer, ja, ja. Es gibt manche Themen, die kann man mir so oft erklären, wie man will. Ich werde es hier immer wieder nicht verstehen, einfach weil es irgendwie, da gibt es irgendwie einen inneren Widerstand oder so. Aber mein Problem ist auch oft, ich gebe irgendwie zu wenig Geld aus. Weil dann heißt es so, ja, das können Sie alles von der Steuer abrechnen. Und ich gucke dann so durch, so was habe ich 2019 ausgegeben. Und am Ende meiner Recherche komme ich auf, hier habe ich 20 Euro gezahlt, weil ich im Parkverbot stand. Kann ich das absetzen? Nein, nein. Gut, dann habe ich nichts. Keine Ausgaben. Gar nichts. Wir haben sie gelebt. Sie haben keine Ausgaben. Nee, du hebst aber die Belege nicht auf. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Und dann versuche ich das alles zu rekonstruieren und dann so, ja, stimmt, die Webseite, ja, genau. Wir haben ja die Webseite. Und dann gucke ich so, das kostet halt so 2,90 Euro im Jahr, indem er halt so Scheiße, man, warum kann das nicht teurer sein? Und vor allem die Teilung setzt du dich durch zwei auch eigentlich. Ja, genau. So, zwei neunzig tippe ich ein, ein Euro fünf und neunzig, ne eins fünf und neunzig. Und dann hast du für den Tag aber auch genug Steuern gemacht. Ich habe jetzt gerade fünf Minuten gebraucht, um vielleicht am Ende sechzig Cent von der Steuer abzusetzen. Bei mir wurde immer gesagt, ich muss meine Belege jetzt sammeln als Selbstständiger und muss dann, am Ende reicht dann einfach, Geschäftsessen draufzuschreiben. Reicht nicht, habe ich jetzt nach drei Monaten erfahren, es reicht nicht, einfach nur Geschäftsessen draufzuschreiben, sondern du musst immer auf den Bewertungs... Genau, du musst immer schreiben, mit Florentin Will, Aufnahme eines, und dann muss man immer sich was ausdenken oder halt die Wahrheit schreiben, eher die Wahrheit schreiben. Und das reicht zum Beispiel nicht. Und dann hieß es immer, Belege sammeln, das habe ich mal gemacht, da habe ich irgendwann einen riesen Haufen Belege gehabt, und dann hieß es immer, du musst die Steuererklärung fertig machen und so. Dann habe ich diesen Belegstapel abfotografiert, eingescannt, was auch immer, hingeschickt, habe aber vergessen, dass ja die meisten Rechnungen und Belege per Mail kommen, weil ja natürlich alle Drive-Now, Car-to-Go, Rollerfahrten oder Taxifahrten alles per Mail kommt, Telekom-Rechnung, alles per Mail. Natürlich sind da die Ausgaben primär. Ich habe dann meine analogen Belege gesammelt und die ja hingeschickt und dachte mir, oh, wow, jetzt mache ich richtig Geld. Völlig absurd, dass man dann, ich habe komplett vergessen, dass es diese Online-Welt ja noch gibt. Nee, aber ich musste auch bei meinem Mieter habe ich irgendwas, bei meinem Vermieter habe ich irgendwas gebraucht, dann habe ich so hingeschrieben, so ja, schicken Sie mir bitte meine Mietkostenabrechnung für 2018, habe ich auch ewig gebraucht, die Mail zu formulieren, ewig vor mir hergeschoben, weil ich dachte mir, eigentlich müsste ich das haben und dann für die Wohnung in Hamburg und dann schicke ich das ab und jetzt habe ich es endlich abgeschickt, endlich habe ich das vom Herzen, Mail kommt zurück, 2018 haben sie noch nicht bei uns gewohnt. Und er hat mir, ja, das ist ein, das ist ein gutes, ein guter Punkt, das ist ein gutes Argument. Darauf bin ich selber.
Das ist korrekt, das stimmt.
Was denkt der jetzt von dir eigentlich? Für wie dumm muss die Person mich bitte halten? Also entweder sieht man für einen Betrüger, dass ich irgendwelche Dokumente, wenn die es noch nicht gibt, oder so, wer weiss denn nicht, wo er wohnt? Ich meine, wie dumm kann man sein? Die Frage wirklich, warst du dann in dem Moment sehr unaufmerksam? Hast du darüber einfach nicht nachdenken wollen? Ja, das ist alles, das verschwimmt, alles, was zwei Jahre her ist, verschwimmt in so einem Gedächtnisbrei bei mir. Keine Ahnung, man, da war irgendwann mal eine Mondlandung, da war irgendwann mal so ein Teleskop, das irgendwie rotiert ist. Hubble, Hubble. Hubble war irgendwann mal, wann war das denn, die 90er, 2000er, weiss. 2000 Nuller, die waren's. Es gibt zu wenig, es gibt keine Epochen mehr, oder? Denkst du mich jetzt zu einer Meinung? Also, nee, nee, sag doch mal, was ist denn deine Meinung zu Epochen? Ich glaube, ich teile ja, Bendy, als vor Corona und nach Corona ist, glaube ich, die Epoche. Nein, ich gebe dir gebe dir natürlich recht. Na also, danke. Es gibt in gewisser Weise keine richtig krassen Epochen mehr. Mir fehlt sowas wie Kreide-Dinosaurier-Zeit, Mittelalter, Ägypten. Mir fehlen diese Was-is-was-Epochen, diese klassischen. Nee, aber auch zum Beispiel, wenn man mal überlegt, das Dritte Reich, Nazi-Zeit, war ja vergleichsweise mega kurz. Dafür, wie anders die Gesellschaft damals war, war das ja mega kurz. Die haben sich anders gegrüsst, die haben sich anders gekleidet, die hatten irgendwie andere Hobbys, die waren in anderen Ländern unterwegs und sowas. Und die haben halt wahrscheinlich ganz anders. Euphemismus. Aber dafür, dass es halt nur zwölf Jahre waren, denkt man sich, was war denn die Zeit zwischen 2000 und 2012? Wie unterscheidet die sich denn von heute? Die haben auch gesagt, hi, was geht. Ja, aber schau mal auf die Handys. Die haben auch Breaking Bad angeschaut. Mein Junge, schau mal auf die Handys. Ja, die Handys, aber so, du kannst du überhaupt nicht gut unterscheiden. Aber ich kann das gar nicht mehr ernst nehmen, Breaking Bad mit diesen Clubhandys und sowas. Ja, aber warum kann man nicht alle zwölf Jahre wirklich so sagen, jetzt ist eine andere Zeit, so andere Kleidung, so Cruise zum Beispiel. Du liest einen Brief aus der NS-Zeit und du weißt sofort, allein durch die Cruise-Formel weißt du sofort, wo wir sind. Wohingegen du liest ein Mail aus 2016, keine Ahnung, wo wir sind. Ich war in Wien in einer Beethoven-Ausstellung, was sonst toll war, weil da waren alte Briefe von ihm ausgestellt, die er an Kumpel geschrieben hat. Und ehrlich gesagt, so anders war das da auch nicht. Echt, war das auch so, ey, was geht, Alter, ich hänge hier doch an dieser Sonate, Mann. Und zwar musste er, er wollte sich abends treffen in einer Bar, die hieß Der Schwan, oder so, zum Schwan, zum Weissen Schwan, sowas. Und dann hat er einem Kumpel geschrieben, und es war mehr oder weniger ein, du kommst heute Abend rum in den Schwan, sonst werde ich dir die Freundschaft kündigen, sonst sehen wir uns nie wieder, sonst ist mir alles egal, ich werde dich nie wieder einladen, ich werde nie wieder fragen, ob du mit mir hinkommst, die Freundschaft, das war's dann, tschau, und dann hat er geschrieben, dein BTHT-H-F-, äh, B-T-H-V-N. Er hat ja die Vokale weggelassen. War es natürlich mega, er war der erste Mensch, der diese Trend hat, an den Schakel war, die Vokale wegzulassen, wenn alle so Brooklyn-Shirts haben und so. Er hat einfach B-T-H-V-N. Bittiffen hat das erfunden. Bittiffen. Alter, was geht. Und es war wirklich auch ein cooler Brief, sehr lustig geschrieben, man kennt ihn nur als grimmigen Zeitgenossen und so. Er war auch gesellig durchaus und hat ein paar Freunde und war auch zu Scherzen aufgelegt. Es zieht sich übrigens durch, dass alle Menschen, die ich mag, von deren Kunst ich angezogen bin und so, alles auch lustige Menschen waren, für die Humor auch immer eine Rolle. Ich tue mich total schwer, das ist mir noch nicht mal so aufgefallen, im Gespräch auch mit jemandem, mit dem es genauso ging, dass ich tue mich selbst schwer mit Künstlern, die kein Humorlevel haben oder kein Ironielevel. Also so Pythagoras oder so ist für dich völlig raus. Ich wette, wenn man da genau nachforscht, ich bin ein großer Pythagoras-Fan, wird man da auch einen Ironie-Layer finden. Zumindest eine gewisse Auseinandersetzung mit Humor. Aber ist auch kein Künstler, du redest gerade von einem Mathematiker. Slash Philosoph. Slam? Der hat viel geslamt. Hat er geslamt? Ja, das ist halt, es lässt sich schlecht überliefern. Ja, auch weil ich die Sprache nicht spreche. Aber ehrlich gesagt, es zieht sich so ein bisschen durch, so die Künstler und so, die sich sehr ernst nehmen. Und es ist auch egal, was für eine Kunst. Aber Leute, die sich zu ernst nehmen und dann immer so wahnsinnig, ja, so einen Stock im Arsch haben, ist, glaube ich, nichts für mich. Ja, es ist super schwer, in der Geschichte festzustellen, welche Dinge ernst gemeint waren oder nicht. Man macht sich dann so auch lustig über, oh, der Künstler hat den Löwen total falsch gemalt. Wo man sich denkt, vielleicht war das ein Gag, vielleicht hat er den aus Scheiss falsch gemalt, vielleicht war das ein Prank oder vielleicht war das eine Karikatur oder vielleicht war das halt so, man ist immer so dabei, so, oh, die können es nicht oder oh, die haben irgendwie so ein... Ja, aber das war so, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben Löwen gesehen. Wir haben ja Flugzeuge, wir können da nicht hinreisen nach Afrika, wir haben keine Ahnung und deswegen deswegen haben die dann einfach aus Spaß lachend dann was gemalt. Kann ja sein. Oder auch so dieses ganze Adalas oder Blutegel, vielleicht war das halt auch einfach nur aus Scheiss oder vielleicht war das nur so ein Prank oder irgendwie so eine Late-Night-Show-Idee, die sich halt irgendwie verselbstständigt hat und die niemand mehr korrigiert hat in der Geschichtsschreibung. Also Ice Bucket Challenge. Ja genau, so die Blutegel Challenge und wir denken, oh Gott, waren die dumm, die dachten das halt Krankheiten. Nee, so, man weiß es nicht genau, es ist total, total schwierig festzustellen, was der Humor, weil Humor, ich habe auch zum Beispiel das Gefühl so, zum Beispiel wir lesen heute ja noch Plato oder sowas oder Aristoteles, so, das kann man heute noch lesen und kann heute noch in der Uni darüber reden. Aber man liest selten Comedy aus alter Zeit. Also niemand würde heutzutage, also ja gut, vielleicht Shakespeare-Komödien, okay, das ist vielleicht das Maximum, aber auch da roffelt man jetzt nicht wirklich ab. Ich habe das Gefühl, Humor hat eine wesentlich kürzere Halbwertszeit. Ich glaube, so das Letzte, was man sich angucken kann, ist vielleicht Chaplin oder so. Ich glaube, davor, oder? Ich meine, so ein Stand-up aus dem Mittelalter, würde man sich das reinziehen? Ja, gab es ja nicht. Ist ja halt ein Gaukler, der jongliert und auf die Nase fällt oder so. Ja. Ja, ja, ist halt anders, ne? Alter. Aber in diesem Brief habe ich mich so wahnsinnig der Zeit auch so nahe gefühlt, weil es total nachvollziehbar war. Und der Brief war dann irgendwie so von 1807 oder so was. Und es war halt total schön und verständlich geschrieben und hat total Spaß gemacht irgendwie. Also der Brief war sehr lustig geschrieben. Mein edler Freund, wie kannst du es wagen, heute Abend nicht zu erscheinen? Mässig, ganz toll, also wie so eine WhatsApp-Nachricht an Kumpel, so wenn du heute Abend nicht kommst, war es das mit uns. Das ist wirklich genau... Klassische WhatsApp-Nachricht auch. Hast du schon mal jemandem eine Freundschaft gekündigt? Ja, ja, durchaus. Ja, aber eher durch Ignorieren und man hat sich aus den Augen gefordert oder dann wirklich so mit Ansage so jetzt aus? Nee, da bin ich dann auch schon dramatisch in dem Moment und lebe das dann auch so aus und dann sage ich, das war's. Ja? Ja, aber dann nach zwei Tagen ist alles gut. Aber was war denn der Grund? Oder einfach Interesse verloren oder gab es Anlässe? Nee, gab es dann auch Anlässe hier und da. Uh. Auf jeden Fall hat man natürlich jeden paar Querellen kam und sich in die Speichen. Aber was, hast du da wirklich gesagt, wir sind keine Freunde mehr oder ich will dich nicht mehr sehen?
Ich glaube, wir können erst mal nicht mehr befreundet sein.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, dann ist auch, ich bin auch kein Mensch, der das durchziehen kann und so.
Und nach zwei Tagen ist dann bei mir auch wieder alles gut.
Ich bin ja auch zu harmoniebedürftig und so.
Ich will das dann aber auch in dem Moment, wo ich auch weiß, dass ich recht habe und so,
will ich das schon dann so ein bisschen auch ausleben.
Ich will dann auch mir meine, die Zeit nehmen, in der ich gerade sauer haben kann, weil das ist der beste Hochstatus. Jemand hat einen Fehler gemacht, sieht's ein, du bist sauer, weisst, dass du recht hast und so, da will ich auch kurz mal Drama und da will ich kurz auch mal sagen, das war's jetzt vielleicht mit uns und der andere, nein, aber dann will ich auch mal die Tränen und das, nein, das tut mir so leid, bitte nicht. Klar, und dann nach einer Stunde ist dann wieder alles gut. Dann einfach so den George Costanza machen, einfach trotzdem dann wiederkommen und dann kann man nichts dagegen machen. Was ja der Larry David war bei SNL. Ja, genau, einfach wieder hinkommen. Aber ich kann mich ja auch nicht gut streiten, ich bin auch nicht gut darin, mich offen zu streiten. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Und wenn dann mal, das war mir neulich beruflich passiert, da habe ich mich ganz doll offen gestritten.
Ich bin ganz, ganz schlecht darin. Ich habe das völlig verlernt.
Klar, wenn du es nicht lernst und nicht übst zu streiten, hast du keine Chance gegen erfahrene Streiter.
Ich war so gegen so einen leicht offenen, ausgesprochenen Streit so nervös plötzlich, mein Herzfinger anzuschlagen, meine Stimme wurde so ganz eng und quietschig und war so gar nicht, war mein Organismus darauf ausgelegt, mehr sich offen zu streiten. Kann ich nicht. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Wir haben uns auch noch nie gestritten. Überhaupt nicht. Nee, ich würde ja auch sofort dem aus dem Weg gehen, weil ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, wie ich mich da verhalten soll. Streiten, einfach laut oder laut, du kennst es ja aus Filmen. Ja, genau, ich würde dann wie in Filmen streiten, so, also das darf doch jetzt nicht wahr sein. Und dann muss man immer so Verallgemeinerungen machen, so, du machst es immer. Jetzt verallgemeiner das doch nicht. Du verallgemeinerst immer. Jetzt ist ja wohl der Opfertausch hier, verdrehst einfach die Sachen wieder. Ach, jetzt bin ich schuld, oder was? Ja, genau. Ach, mehr hast du jetzt dazu nicht zu sagen. Ja, das kennen wir ja schon. Immer das Gleiche mit uns, ne? Ach, jetzt geht das wieder los. Ja, genau, jetzt geht das wieder los, weil sonst sprichst du mit mir ja nicht darüber. Du, ich sag dir mal eins, so geht's nicht weiter mit uns. Ja, dann war's das jetzt hier wohl, oder was? Ja, dann war's das eben. Wenn du durch diese Tür gehst, dann war es das mit uns. Ja, wie soll ich denn sonst aus dem Raum kommen? Gibt ja nur eine Tür bei dir! Ja, weil du die andere nicht bauen wolltest! So, und jetzt, jetzt bist du zu weit gegangen. Das ist spannend, weil jemand geht dann so ruhig, witzelruhig, und dann gibt es diesen kleinen Cut-off. So, reinge... Und jetzt gehe ich. Ich... Klopfst du? So Schritte. Schritte, okay. Ja, aber so stellen zwei Leute, die sich nicht streiten, Streits vor. Ja, es ist schwierig. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was der Plural von Streits ist. So wenig streite ich mich. Streits? Ja, glaube ich schon. Streits, streits, streits, streits, streits, weiss ich gar nicht. Finde ich immer so ein bisschen faul, wenn man sich dann in so ein anderes Wort pflichtet. Vielleicht kommt das aber noch irgendwann so, wenn man dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, jemanden kennenlernt, der gerne streitet und man muss das so nachholen und so üben. Das weiß ich gar nicht. Vielleicht muss es auch gar nicht sein. Ich bin froh, dass sich Leute offen streiten können. Offen, weil das, ich glaube, da haben eher wir eine Schwäche. Das stimmt. Weil wir, natürlich kokettieren wir gerade so ein bisschen damit und sagen, wir streiten uns nicht, wir sind zu harmoniebedürftig, wir sind zu toll. Nee, ich glaube auch, dass es nicht so ist. Ich glaube, das ist, glaube ich, keine gute Eigenschaft. Ich glaube, sich auch mal streiten zu können, ist wirklich wahnsinnig wichtig. Offen Gefühle zeigen zu können. Ich glaube, die Kunst des Streitens ist ja, danach dann wieder weiterzumachen. Also so glaube ich, vielleicht ist es ja so, dass gesunde Beziehungen oder so sich oft streiten, so ein reinigendes Streiten, aber dann auch wissen, wie man dann wieder zusammenkommt. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich habe nur mal in diesen Podcast reingehört von Charlotte Roche und ihrem Mann, und die reden auch darüber, dass sie sich ständig streiten und ständig fetzen, und ich dachte mir so, okay, aber auf einem krassen Level und dann auch mit Sachen werfen und so. Und dann aber auch auf so einer, also die da irgendwie total gesund mit umgehen und das auch total interessant besprechen. Also absolut sowieso schöner Podcast, auch wenn ich nur die erste Folge gehört habe, ehrlich gesagt, weil es interessiert mich dann doch nicht genug. Aber die erste Folge hat, man kann ja auch mal sagen, man hat eine Folge genossen, aber man muss nicht mehr. Man hat den Zeitpunkt gemerkt, wo du entschieden hast, nicht mit der Lüge zu gehen, gerade.
Nee. Da gab es einen kurzen Moment
eine Ammoderation, wo ich dachte, jetzt geht das
vielleicht durch. Nee, ich hatte tatsächlich ein schlechtes Gewissen, ob ich
einen Podcast empfehlen kann, wo ich nur die erste Folge gehört habe.
Aber manchmal holst du dir halt eine Kugel
Vanilleeis und isst die und es reicht. So, und dann
passt es auch. Ja. Gut, das ist jetzt wirklich
noch nie passiert. Aber dann halt
muss vielleicht auch keiner dann noch dazukommen.
Ja. Nee, aber vielleicht ist es ja auch total gesund. Ist wahrscheinlich gesund. Es ist wahrscheinlich frustrierend für Leute, mit anderen Leuten zusammen zu sein, mit denen sie nicht streiten können. Das belastet dir wahrscheinlich mehr. Ja, weil Dinge unausgesprochen bleiben, glaube ich. Wahrscheinlich kann ich auch streiten, um euch zu sein. Ja? Ja, ich weiß nicht. Worüber könnten wir uns streiten, so richtig? Das ist dann so ein... Ihr seht uns, glaube ich, auch zu selten. Wir haben genug Zeit... Nee, kreativ können wir uns schon streiten, da haben wir uns auch schon mal häufig. Aber nicht gestritten, das war ja dann halt... Also das ist ja nie persönlich. Das ist ja rein, geschmacklich, kreativ, aber da haben wir uns schon richtig doll diskutiert. Ja, da sind wir dann auch vehement, da geben wir beide nicht nach. Nee, aber das ist auch gut, glaube ich. Da können wir eben, weil es hat jetzt letztens mal wieder jemand kommentiert, wo denn die Gute Arbeit Originals-Folge bleibt, können wir irgendwann mal machen, ist das natürlich blöd, jetzt alle zusammenzurufen, aber da können wir auch mal drüber reden, weil da gab es ja auch einige wirkliche Auseinandersetzungen, in welche kreative Richtung es gehen soll. Ich habe nämlich heute, zufälligerweise, weil ich ein Foto von Katja gebraucht habe, noch ein paar alte Sketche reingeguckt und ich weississ dann immer noch immer genau so, was haben wir uns gestritten für einzelne Zeilen oder Ausrichtungen. Und dann gab es, der Raum hat sich immer gespalten, aber interessanterweise immer anders. Es gab immer nie zwei Fronten. Aber auch nie Mittel, es gab nie die Mitte. Es gab nie jemanden, der gesagt hat, nee, das ist mir jetzt eigentlich egal. Es gab immer nur zwei Schnittfassungen und dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Tarkan und du habt gesagt, nee, eins und Katja und ich haben gesagt, nee, zwei und dann gab es auch da immer andere Gruppen, immer zwei gegen zwei. Vier ist keine gute Zahl für eine Gruppe. Immer ungerade in der Gruppe sein. Aber auch geil, dass, ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es fast schon zu spät auch für diesen Podcast, weil wir werden vieles verklären. Es gab mal eine Zeit, also da, es gab eine Zeit, da habe ich sehr sentimental auf die Zeit zurückgeschaut, dann gab es eine Zeit, wo ich dann dachte, ja, das ist schon alles sehr verklärt. Das war schon auch ganz schön viel harte Arbeit, viele Streits und sehr viel eigene Verantwortung und wow, da muss man auch schon mit einem gewissen Budget gerade arbeiten und irgendwann war man sich der Verantwortung bewusst und hat man es aber auch ausgeblendet und jetzt gerade vermisst man es dann doch wieder, weil diese Zeit dann auch wieder doch zu lange her ist, also würde wahrscheinlich wieder eine verkehrter Folge. Wir müssen mal, ob wir die richtige Phase treffen. Wir müssen die richtige Phase treffen. Ich weiß nicht, welche Phase als nächstes kommt.
Nee, aber ja.
Nee, meine ich nur, aber da gab es schon Auseinandersetzungen.
Es ist immer so schwer, wie man dann weiterkommt,
weil man denkt sich so, ja, ich habe ja Recht, aber ich weiß ja, dass mein Recht haben auch nur aus meiner persönlichen Perspektive ist. Wobei, das muss man sagen, wir beide haben schon häufig hinbekommen, dass wir einander überzeugt haben. Das stimmt, ja. Aber dann beide den anderen so gut überzeugt haben, dass dann wieder ein grossartiger Streit entführt wurde. Dass ich dann deine Meinung verteidigt habe und du meine und wir uns wieder nicht einig waren. Genau, weil, und das habe ich bei dir das Gefühl, dass man dich auch überzeugen kann. Und du hast es bei mir wahrscheinlich auch. Das habe ich auch schon mal geschafft und du bei mir sicherlich auch schon mal. Wie gesagt, auch schon mal, so dass wir uns beigeflippt sind, aber von daher glaube ich, sind dann
deswegen die Streits auch so krass, weil wir ja auch
dann tendenziell das Gefühl haben,
da könnte ja ein Licht am Ende dieses furchtbaren
Meinungsturnels sein.
Von daher, üben
zu streiten, ist glaube ich ganz gut.
Wenn ihr da draußen jetzt
vielleicht zu zweit irgendwo in der
Isolation steckt, streitet
euch oder gebt uns mal Tipps, gute Streiten, was habt ihr für Erfahrungen gemacht? Wir müssen uns mal hier im Podcast vielleicht streiten vor den anderen. Mal einmal Dinge sagen, die man nicht mag, am anderen. Ich glaube, wir können auch immer gut uns aus dem Weg gehen. Das glaube ich auch, dass man sich eher streitet, wenn man sich nicht mehr aus dem Weg gehen kann. Ja und Humor. Gerade so Urlaub oder so, wo man dann immer aufeinandersetzt, da ist glaube ich immer so streitanfällig, wo dann irgendwann einfach es kippt. Oder Humor ist ja auch dann der grösste Feind des Streits, weil der Humor ja natürlich einfach die Distanz. Ich glaube, dafür sind wir dann immer zu, haben dann so eine weirder Vogelperspektive. Wie wieder, das klingt mir ja so, als wenn man das so toll, aber ist es ja auch blöd. Und dann hat man so eine Distanz, baut man dann immer wieder da rein, weil man sagt, wie lächerlich ist das eigentlich gerade?
Gibt es auch so viele Leute, die dann, also Autoren und so,
die dann immer zwischendurch aufschreiben während Streits,
die sich aufschreiben wollen für später,
Judd Appetau macht das, glaube ich, manchmal.
Ja.
Der schreibt sich mit seiner Frau und schreibt ab und zu,
dann setzt er auf, die gefallen sind.
Ja, ja, das war ganz gut.
Ja.
Aber manchmal ist es auch einfach schwer, sich aufzuregen sinnvoll, weil es wirkt oft lächerlich. Gerade so im Auto oder so habe ich manchmal echte Wutausbrüche, weil da kann es echt passieren. Und letztens habe ich wirklich mal, weil ich hau dann auch rum und hau dann auf den Beifahrersitz oder so, wenn da niemand sitzt. In der Regel sitzt da niemand. Aber letztens habe ich auch auf die Hupe gehauen und es gibt kein lustigeres Geläsch als eine Hupe. Und dann denke ich so, verdammt noch! Dann denkst du einfach nur so, okay, komm, ist einfach schon lustig. Ich muss auch bei einer Autohupe immer lachen. Wenn ich bei mir allein in der Wohnung sitze und irgendwo an der Struhe ist, dann ist es so, und ich muss immer lachen. Ich finde es immer lustig. Ja, aber das ist nicht immer die Ente. Es ist nicht immer die Ente. Es ist manchmal ist häufig auch ein Ja, na gut, so ein längeres ist ein aggressives. Aber es ist immer lustig. Ich muss immer lachen. Die quaken. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist schon aufhörtlich ein lustiges. Die Frage ist, ob da Autos auch mal in eine andere Richtung gehen, um da ein anderes Geräusch zu machen. Weil das kommt ja immer aus dieser Zeit, wo du so einen Gummiball gedrückt hast. Und ob man da nicht einfach mal sagt. Oder wie diese, man kann sich diese Fahrräder neuerdings leihen, diese Swapfeeds, wo man sich ein Fahrrad leitet, da hat man das für eine Zeit und es ist aber dann sein Fahrrad trotzdem. und man kann damit machen, was man will, ausser alles kaputt machen und es wird viel dafür getan und wenn man ein Schloss kaputt ist, wird es ausgelaut, alles gut, kannst du einfach dann abbestellen und dann holt es jemand wieder ab, ist dein Fahrrad auf Zeit, gute Idee und ein Kumpel hat das und der hat, die haben alle diese Klingel und es ist diese Klischee Ring Ring Klingel. Ja, toll. Also du machst einmal betätigst dich das, aber es ist ein Hin und Zurück ein Hin und zurück, ein Ring Ring. Es ist das Geräusch, wo man sagt, wenn du bei Pokémon das Fahrrad anwählst, kommt das Geräusch. Wenn du in einem Spiel bist und du klickst auf ein Fahrrad, immer kommt das Geräusch. Das Klischee Ring Ring und du kannst noch so aggressiv sein und Fussgänger stehen auf dem Fahrradweg, wenn du auf Leute zurast und ring ring passiert nichts. Niemand hat Angst, alle denken an Rollenspiele und wollen Fahrrad fahren. Es ist genau wie dieses Pferde-Wihern, wo es dieses eine Wihern gibt. Und immer wenn du in einem Film Pferd siehst oder irgendwie so eine Stallanlage immer dieses eine konkrete Wihern, das immer gleich ist. Wuhu! Ja, genau. Aber das Klischee, wenn Leute in Filmen oft in Akt zwei auf den Drachen springen oder bei Avatar auf diese Vögel springen, immer dieses Wuhu! Ja, stimmt, ja, genau. Da gibt es auch immer ein Klischee. Gibt es bestimmt auch bei Harry Potter auf so einem Besen. In jedem Film. Ja, ne, auch auf dem, wir begreifen. Ja, stimmt, ja, genau. Ist immer in jedem Film ein so ein Yeah! Aber auch wenn du einfach da daneben sitzt und sagst so, was, was war das? Ja, eher halt Uh! Uh! Uh! Yeah! Solche Geräusche sind auch toll, so diese, die man macht, um Emotionen auszudrücken, aber man macht sie alleine oder es ist auch so eine Achterbahn, das Schreien, finde ich faszinierend die Geräusche, aber das ist nicht so schlimm. Es ist nicht so schlimm, das passiert dir selten, muss man sagen. Nee, ich wollte genau zum Thema Hupen, weil so diese ganzen Verkehrssachen sind ja alle total genormt und werden ja abgenommen von hohen Behörden.
Muss man als Autohersteller den Hub toten? Gibt es da Vorgaben? Ja, ich glaube schon. Muss man das irgendwie abnehmen lassen, weil dann irgendwie beim Verkehrsministerium? Beim Hubministerium. Ja, weil du hast ja eigentlich ... Dann klingelt man da an, man kommt dann so hin, ist ein stressiger Tag, aber jetzt muss ich bei denen auch noch die Hupe abnehmen lassen, morgen muss ich Vergaser abnehmen lassen, lassen, alles klar. Geht man schnell hin zum Hupministerium und dann steht man davor, die wird telefonisch keiner erreicht, weil die trödeln ein bisschen alle da und dann klingelt man da an und es ist einfach nur so ein und dann kommt man rein, dann geht die Tür auf mit so einem grossen und dann kann man reingehen, dann muss man das anmelden. Ja, und dann so, jetzt spielen wir es mal vor. Ja, passt. Das sind die Normen. Es ist okay, aber ich meine, es gibt ja jetzt wenig so independent Autoproduzenten, oder? Gibt es so wirklich kleine Autofirmen? Nee, oder? Es gibt auch kleinere Autofirmen, ja. Aber so richtig kleine. Die müssen ja auch Masse produzieren. Aber so viel Reich sind ja handgemachte Unikate. Es gibt ja keine Massenproduktion, Fließbandproduktion. Deswegen sind die ja auch so teuer. Das macht es dann irgendwie wieder, also so uncool wie Ferrari sind, das macht es dann wieder ein bisschen cool, dass sie so, wie so ein Modellauto ist eigentlich ein, naja, niemand wird sich Ferrari kaufen. Hallo, ich spar, ich spar seit Jahren.
Ja genau, car to go, car to go, car to go, Ferrari, Ferrari, got my Rari, got my Rari, ja, jedenfalls das macht es dann ein bisschen cool, weil es irgendwie ist wie so ein Revell-Auto, was man selber gebaut hat, nur halt im Maßstab eins zu eins. Ja. Es ist so von scratch gebaut nochmal. Das macht es dann irgendwie wieder ein bisschen gut. Ich frag mich nur, wenn man jetzt ein neues Auto baut, ob man dann nicht eine spezielle Hupe einbauen kann oder ob dann wirklich jemand kommt und sagt, nee, das kann ich machen. Nee, wir haben jetzt als Hupe. Ja. so, nee, es geht. Ich glaube, ich mir die ganze Zeit denke, das ist ein Tipp da draußen an die ganzen Rollerhersteller. Macht ein Game draus an die Melodie, die kommt, wenn man einen Roller entsperrt. Das ist immer eine schöne Melodie. Die beste Melodie hat natürlich mit Abstand Lime, sind wir uns alle einig. Kennt die nicht. Kommt und dann kann man losfahren. So, und das Beste wäre, es gibt auch noch die Marke Tier. Die Marke Tier macht kein spannendes Geräusch, wenn man dies entsperrt. Deswegen macht bei jedem Roller ein anderes Tiergeräusch. Ein Pferde wie ein, ein Elefanten, ein Gorilla, so. Und es ist erstens immer ein grosser Spaß. Hey, welches Geräusch hattest du? Ich hatte aber einen Schimpansen. Ich hatte eine Giraffe. Wie bei der Filmen, wie der Insta-Story, du hast dann so ein Wäääh! Genau. Was ist das für ein Geräusch? Mein Tier hat aber ein komisches Geräusch gemacht. Genau! Was soll das denn sein? Wääb, wääb. Und dann sagt jemand, ja, das ist das Geräusch, was eine südafrikanische Springmaus macht in der Brunftszeit. Das ist dann spannend. Und wenn man halt viele zusammen gesammelt hat vielleicht und dann hat man, haben die alle andere Symbole auch, je nach Tier und dann, wenn man viele gesammelt hat, kriegt man vielleicht Rabatt oder sowas. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich glaube aber auch, dass es oft schwer ist, Filmen Vorschläge zu schicken. Einfach, du schickst ihnen so, hey, wie wäre es denn, wenn, wahrscheinlich in dem Moment löschen die das schon einfach direkt.
Weil es ist einfach...
Was wäre wenn Bullshit-Filter? Ja, das ist so wie, also nichts dagegen, wir lesen natürlich immer gern, was ihr uns schickt, aber oft schicken uns heute auch so Themenvorschläge oder so, nehmen wir nie an, weil weil wir reden über das, über das wir reden wollen, außer wir rufen explizit dazu auf. Aber das ist dann auch immer so, wo ich denke, so was kriegen Firmen wahrscheinlich auch so, so irgendwie so Mannerwaffeln, mach doch mal so Waffeln, die halt so ein bisschen länger sind, aber dafür dünner. Genau wie es jetzt zum viralen Hit geworden ist, dass ein Twitter-User die Fischstäbchen-Pizza durchbringen will bei Dr. Oetker.etker. Und mittlerweile weiß Doktor Oetker, kann es nicht mehr wegignorieren, weil es so ein Mini-Biral-Hit geworden ist, dass der Typ hat unter jedem Post von Doktor Oetker geschrieben, ja, oder bring doch mal die Fischstäbchen-Pizza raus. Ja, oder wie wär's denn mal mit etwas Fischigem? Er hat immer den Tweet genommen und dann schön darauf geantwortet, war sehr lustig. Und jetzt ist, glaube ich, die Fischstäbchen-Pizza nicht mehr so weit entfernt. War natürlich mega cool jetzt, wenn es die dann wirklich gibt irgendwann, das macht es ja noch zum größeren Hit. Stimmt, eigentlich eine gute Idee. Vielleicht ist das auch eine Marketingkampagne, dass die diesen Account selber faken und dass die selber eigentlich schon planen, nächstes Jahr eine Fischstäbchenpizza rauszubringen und es so durch so einen viralen Hit machen wollen. Das wäre mind-boggling.
Das wäre so...
Ja, du, es gibt Leute,
die studieren Werbung und so.
Es muss doch Leute geben,
die einfach... Du hast doch brillante Köpfe
in der Werbeindustrie, wo du sagst,
okay, wir müssen uns das irgendwas überlegen. Und vieles
davon geht wahrscheinlich schief und wir kriegen es
nie mit. Ja, wahrscheinlich geht es viel schief. Ja, aber die Tieridee finde ich gut. Ich finde, das sollte man so machen. Machen wir so. Machen wir auf jeden Fall so. Die App kann das ja auch machen, oder? Weil der Roller selber ist dann vielleicht schwierig. Der Roller macht das. Ja, aber kann das nicht die App machen? Ja, hab ich auch. Und dann kann man in der App halt so ein paar Soundfights, weil ich glaube, im Roller ist es schwer, weil dann musst du das noch irgendwie. Ja, ist okay. Weil wenn die Apps macht. Ja, ist halt ein bisschen schlechter, aber ist okay. Und dann zeigt dir die App ein Bild von dem Tier? Oder eben gerade nicht? Nee, Ratespiel. Erstmal Ratespiel. Vielleicht auch ein Bild. Bin ich offen. Ich will nur ein bisschen ... Mäu! Was? Mäu! Ziege. Zikarde.
Schnelle, schnelle Ratte. Welches, hat mir schon mal gefragt, welches Tier kannst du am besten nachmachen? Der vorbeirasende Wal. Toll. Wir wünschen euch eine fantastische Woche.
Ja, geht mal raus.
Macht alles richtig, macht alles richtig, habt eine schöne Zeit, haut rein. Bleibt sicher, steckt einander nicht an und hört unbedingt in den NDR Info-Podcast rein, wo der Virologe Herr Drosten von der Bindia Charite jeden Tag, das ist mein neuer Einschlaf-Podcast, am Anfang habe ich noch gebannt zugehört, mittlerweile schlage ich dazu ein.
Es wird so ein bisschen ungesunde Normalität,
aber hört in den Virologen-Podcast rein,
da werdet ihr gut informiert.
Macht immer Spaß, den zuzuhören.
Macht's gut, bis dann, hat rein.
Bis dann, ciao, ciao.